God is it nice to be here I'm dealing
with a possum problem at the house just
moved into a new house
me and my wife would like to go in the
yard at night have a little wine and
these possums are comfortable like if
they could talk they'd be like what the
hell are you doing here now growing up I
grew up in an immigrant family and how
we handle possums racoons my father
would be like we're gonna murder the
best gonna pour antifreeze on Bologna
what woke up in the morning birds
squirrels raccoons just murdered all
over our property
neighbors coming by have you seen our
cat now we haven't seen it check the
yard but my wife she didn't grow up this
way we got to call the possum police
it's a humane service they come over
$150 traps guy tells me it's $35 extra
for the for the bait I said what are you
using is like a peanut butter
$35 for venema I got dollar 23 jiffy
inside okay honey tells me it's $75 per
possum that he removes so where are you
taking the posit it's like I Drive them
30 miles away I let him go
in Malibu now I don't believe a word
this guy's telling me I think he goes
down the block let's sit up he's making
$75 I'm the same person I say you think
I'm bum first one we catch I spray paint
I'm tagging the posse
the guy came over like I've never seen a
blue one before I said yeah and if I see
it again we're gonna have a problem not
take the thing to Malibu but I don't
know if you people have ever had like a
trap in your yard but it brings an
excitement to the house every few hours
me and my wife were going to the window
we catch one morning we caught a
squirrel the guy told me this would
happen
squirrel could get in there it's like if
it does just let it go so I went to go
take the squirrel out something was
wrong with the squirrel I don't know
what was going on and foaming at the
mouth okay I go I I'm not letting this
out my luck I let it out this thing's
all over me I'm not fighting a squirrel
on a Tuesday morning at 7:30 so I give
my wife a 20
[Applause]
I thought I'd go across the street
there's a Mexican gardener across the
street Mexicans are not as scared of
anything don't come over with their bare
hands get it out and throw it on the
sidewalk so ten minutes goes by she
calls me from the driveway
she's got three Mexican gardeners with
her I said the whole reason for you to
go do this was to act like you were home
alone and you didn't want to let the
swirl now I gotta look three grown men
in the eye the swirls back here we're
kind of scared it's foaming at the mouth
can you do it you guys have been great
happy holiday
[Applause]
you